cher toit, j'ai encore rêvé de toi la
nuit dernière, je garde ton visage dans mon esprit, je
pense à tes cheveux qui s'allongent, je pense
à ton ventre qui grossit, je pense
à ta petite fille, j'ai
tiré sur quelqu'un, je crois que j'ai tiré sur quelqu'un,
je suis confuse, Ruth,
je ne le fais pas.  Je ne sais pas pourquoi vous les enfants avez fait ce que vous
avez fait,
que voulez-vous faire maintenant, je vais l'
attendre
plus tard, j'ai pensé à vos cheveux cette
fois, un ami ouais, ce que je sais, vous savez,
je suis absent et j'espère que vous savez.  Je viens
pour toi comme je l'ai toujours dit,
je me lance dans tout ça tout seul, tout ce que
j'ai à faire c'est de dire la vérité,
peu importe ce que tu as fait
quand je te vois avec ta fille,
tout ce que je vois c'est  bien
ouais
les gens parlent de regret mais je n'y suis pas
arrivé J'ai voyagé haut et loin et maintenant
bien sûr je suis si proche de toi je peux
presque tendre la main et toucher ta joue
tu prends ces filles et tu as
des problèmes
peut-être que tu l'as fait  Je n'ai pas le temps jusqu'à ce que tout
ça se termine, même jusqu'à ce qu'il se fasse
attraper,
tu l'as vu,
nous pouvons y arriver, nous pouvons y arriver,
bonne journée, je me réveille et aujourd'hui est le
jour où je te verrai
ces jours-là
et nous pourrons rouler.  en route vers quelque part,
quelque part au loin